on l'avait dit maintenant à notre thé ou
de la semaine
les gens quand je suis
gérard louvin bonsoir
on se demandait où vous étiez passé de
plaisir que vous aviez quitté touche pas
à mon poste en fait vous prépariez un
spectacle on va en parler mais d'abord
alors vous avez révélé avoir voulu
quitter touche pas à mon poste quand
cyril hanouna vous a annoncé que nabila
allait devenir chroniqueuse et vous avez
déclaré je ne tenais pas à m'asseoir à
côté d'elle c'est là on voit que vous
êtes homosexuel
ya de quoi
les deux ans que j'ai fait je me suis
beaucoup amusé mais quand il m'a dit il
ya un habile à ça ça m'a dit je m'assois
pas côtés de nabil ben on parle de
télévision au départ moi je vois pas je
ne voyais pas ce qu'elle a à dire sur
les médias nabila bat pas vraiment alors
c'est vrai que depuis quelques temps il
y avait de l'eau dans gaz vous aviez été
suspendu d'antenne pour avoir giflé un
assistant et en fait ce que cyril vous
reprocher c'est d'avoir fait ça hors
antenne
on avait un jour je raconterai
l'histoire la vraie alors après la
carrière que vous avez fait qu'un énorme
c'est vrai que c'est un peu bizarre de
voir comme ça
c'est un peu pour ça que sert à tout
comme ça
la musique y est devenu gros gégé qua
non mais
spécialement genot loin d'en face de moi
noël j'ai produit quand même 5 tournée
de star en moins et je voyais dans son
regard ouais ali c'est pas lui c'est un
peu ça alors je les fais une fois je les
fais deux fois j'ai fait trois fois j'ai
fait quatre fois bout d'un moment j'ai
dit j'arrête quoi je peux pas je fais
pas je me suis amusé mais une fois de
temps en temps mais maman je comprends
très bien mais on regarde la tête que
j'ai jeu et encore on voit pas mais là
tu as des douilles dans le slip c'est
gérard voilà
pour gérard
alfred et lille lui fromont on dira un
serial killer alias géant louvain tout
commence le 5 septembre
1946 pour ainsi en banlieue parisienne 9
kg cette année font vos parents tiennent
un salon de coiffure pour dames
et après la fermeture
la boutique tient lieu de salle à manger
vers l'âge de 4 ans vous rêvez déjà
gérard de spectacle fait le show dans le
cérémonie familiale
aura ainsi gérés par les cirques
à 13 ans dans votre bain vous
interviewez vous même alors monsieur
gérard racontez-nous vos débuts
comment avez vous réussi et ça c'est
touchant et bigoudis en plus
présent
à 18 ans vous travaillez dans les trains
de luxe mais les week-ends vous avez un
groupe de rock est chanteur et votre
groupe s'appelle les play-boys way
pour que vous voyez
vous fait les premières parties de
jacques dutronc de michel polnareff
talida way sinon ici à l'époque mais
alors au départ en fait gérard bull y
est dans la lumière c'est peut-être pour
ça que vous avez fait ce jour à mon
poste je me suis réveillé je me suis
réveillé artists après j'ai vu je savais
que j'avais passé de talent et je me
suis arrivé à nîmes at her et quand j'ai
pensé à faire de la télévision je
voulais présenter ma première émission
j'ai fait un essai ge était à chier donc
j'ai aussi compris que c'était prendre
un truc donc j'évite était derrière la
caméra mais si ça se trouve en fait
cette première décision c'est à dire de
devenir un chanteur dans un groupe de
rock c'est peut-être ce pour quoi vous
étiez fait nous vous êtes a peur d'avoir
raté quelque chose j'étais chanteur
s'était chanteur ringard harry avait
chanté en yaourt chanter un peu où c'est
comme chanter les chansons dell pèse
pour un flirt avec toi un peu non mais
je savais je chantais 30 à 40 chansons
par par soir puisque j'étais dans un bal
j'étais tout sauf un vrai bon chanteur
alors c'est avec claude françois donc
que vous apprendrez la direction
artistique est là la production site
avec lui vous avez appris être odieux
avec le personnel non parce qu'ils
n'étaient pas au dieu et que le
personnel sait on est habillé en a pris
les trois baisses des concepts des
concierge de l'hôtel de m qui est
derrière et on joue au concierge on
reçoit les clients c'est un mec génial
j'ai travaillé avec lui il avait 33 ans
33 ans il était patron de société et
c'est vachement important il avait
fléchi l'avait absolue il avait podium
il avait tout ça et le soir malgré tous
ces soucis on lui disait allez va
chanter le lundi au soleil sais c'est
pas toujours facile alors temps en temps
a été de mauvaise humeur imaginez que
vous l'après toutes les missions vous
tournez vous tournez je le dis bah on
part à lille doit faire une heure et
demie de seine je suis pas sûr ensuite
vous lancerez dans le management
d'artistes donc avec lio palmade pagny
j'étais producteur de palmade j'étais
producteur kavanagh brut sur florent
pagny pour le tour michel leeb
producteurs de plein de choses grand
producteur mais aussi du mime marceau et
aussi de maurice béjart mais aussi
d'alliages les textes d'alliages été
meilleurs que ceux des mines marsaudon
mais nous avons attaqué journal en place
devrait
ensuite produire des pièces goûter à des
comédies musicales des émissions de
télévision dont sacrée soirée alors il
paraît que le titre de sacrés soit je
sais pas si c'est vrai mais c'est en
hommage à une partouze géante
organisée chez vous non c'est pas sympa
pour le petit garçon qu'il ya 13 heures
qu'ils la trouvaient pas ce qu'on avait
fait un concours et ment pas tu as payé
sa dette pour ça
on m'a raconté que c'est jean pierre
foucault il est là ce soir voici gens
bien foucault
mais pas là alors on attend que tout on
la tient trois colloques ont tourné la
tête
alors gérard vous êtes ici ce soir pour
audi no qui votent nouvelle production
musicale à bobino du 19 janvier au 29
avril agen spectacle faut le dire assez
étonnant dans le cas d'un grand
orchestre symphonique reprend des
chansons contemporaines
et là on réalise en fait qu'avec 18
violent et 14 compet n'importe quelle
chanson de merde hadja galles non mais
c'est vrai 'cependant sympa pour adèle
et pour daft punk et pour michel legrand
il pourrait dit piaf etc oui c'est vrai
mais je veux dire que ce soit des gens
sont des merdes et ses codes des jeunes
musiciens c'est un jeune chef
d'orchestre qu'apple si loin dinos qui a
la passion de la musique qui fait c'est
très important qui fait partager sa
passion de la musique parle plus au
public sir qui fait monter des gens non
musiciens sur scène qui joue à del
il descend dans la salle pour faire des
percussions c'est une vraie expérience
musicale vous sûrs que c'est vraiment
formidable on regarde à gauche ensemble
de 10 nous la rencontre surprenante
entre des grands thèmes populaires
classiques et des standards de la pop
[Musique]
de michael jackson à édith piaf en
passant par adele ou stravinsky
audineau transcende les genres musicaux
en toute légèreté avec une grande
liberté
[Musique]
le public partage et vit des moments
d'émotion et de surprises
[Musique]
grâce à l'interaction le public devient
lui aussi musicien et acteur de cette
soirée ludique et magique
du 19 janvier au 29 avril en bout ce
n'est que du bonheur c'est gentil et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu